en 1982 y senabre tomó el poder por las
armas y se convirtió en el tercer
presidente de chad un régimen que
comenzó marcado por la represión sus
detractores ya fueran verdaderos
opositores o sospechosos de serlo fueron
arrestados y después torturados detrás
de los muros de esta edificación yacen
los recuerdos de años de sufrimiento y
martirio a sí misma él fue encerrado en
este calabozo dice será una de las
varias víctimas de la tiranía de hist en
abre así lo recordaba él mismo de vuelta
al lugar
estábamos en celdas pequeñas de tres
metros por cuatro que no podían albergar
más de diez personas pero en las que
estábamos hasta 27 garcía avance hubo
muchos muertos aunque ella y buque
dispersión que somos
una comisión de investigación cifraría
posteriormente en más de 40.000 los
fallecidos o ejecutados bajo el mandato
de apb en 1990 uno de sus antiguos
generales ido hey débil lo sacó del
poder
reacio a abandonar el país y se nave
encontró refugio en senegal en donde
vivió de manera tranquila por más de 20
años pero en 2011 el presidente
abdoulaye wade sorpresivamente decidió
que ya no era bienvenido y senabre fue
arrestado el 30 de junio de 2013 en
dakar y después en 2016 condenado a
cadena perpetua por un tribunal especial
de la unión africana